adam please me complace anunciar que
ahora tenemos un acuerdo que allana el
camino para que finlandia y suecia
entren en la otan
su joint neto
sonrisas y apretones de manos señales de
alivio después de más de tres horas de
negociaciones turquía se dio por fin
aceptó el ingreso en la otan de
finlandia y suecia
turquía finlandia y suecia han firmado
un memorando que aborda las
preocupaciones de turquía incluso en lo
que respecta a la exportación de armas y
la lucha contra el terrorismo
hasta ahora recep tayip erdogán parecía
inflexible sobre el ingreso de los dos
países los acusó de albergar a
militantes del pkk el partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán una
organización considerada terrorista por
ankara el lunes de estocolmo intentó
tranquilizar al presidente turco sweet
and stud's suecia no es ni será un
refugio para los terroristas las
autoridades competentes están trabajando
intensamente para deportar a las
personas que podrían suponer una amenaza
para la seguridad y se están tramitando
un número importante de casos
y el presidente finés aseguró que pese
al acuerdo finlandia mantendrá sus
propias normativas respecto a las
posibles deportaciones solicitadas por
ankara aunque tuvimos que ceder we will
follow oso a partir de ahora seguiremos
la legislación finlandesa we do not have
an in it to make change is pico saudíes
no tenemos necesidad de hacer cambios
debido a este acuerdo
y en lo que respecta a las deportaciones
podemos seguir nuestra práctica habitual
y con el último paso será el miércoles
cuando los países de la otan inviten
formalmente a suecia finlandia a unirse
a la alianza